welcome to the rich eisen show one of my
favorite actors and i'm not just saying
that because he's kind enough to zoom in
in support of his show american rust
that premieres on sunday
september 12th at 10 p.m eastern time on
showtime the emmy award winner jeff
daniels here on the rich eisen show how
are you sir
i'm good you i'm doing very well i'm
sure because this is a radio audience as
well i need to describe
what i'm seeing there seems to be a lot
of uh string
um
guitars behind you right there what what
am i seeing behind you where where are
you zooming in from jeff what is this
some actors
prefer cocaine i i went with acoustic
guitars and it's it's
uh it's as i've got too many of them i i
got a lot of martin's decade you know
20s 30s 40s and and i just i love them i
play and so that's been my kind of
fetish if you will so there they are
right behind me that's the uh can i is
this like can we have some sort of
contest like guess how many jelly beans
are in the jar i mean uh uh
it it strikes me as uh
would that be about 25 string
instruments behind you jeff what would
it be
yes and there are other places where a
few more i probably by the end of it
have like 30 35 my son is a musician and
as a band and so he's got a few and so
we have this kind of home recording
studio where we store everything and and
uh work out of and it's uh it's great
they're like old friends that you've had
for years you just hang them on the wall
and
and then when you're gone hand them to
your kid
so uh this being uh i guess the fodder
of a show in which there's a lot of
sports talk and pop culture talk i'll
i'll kind of put this in in the
phraseology of of a show like this one
your greatest guitar player of all time
what would your mount rushmore be if i'd
have put you put the four up there jeff
daniels oh well there's there's electric
and i i i really love joe bonamassa a
lot
and yet
just for the the i just i just love joe
uh there are people like buddy guy
then you get into the acoustic players
like stephan grossman and john
fehe and john renborn stefan and john
renborn with two albums together i
remember hearing those in the 70s doc
watson was somebody i heard and said how
does he do what he does and tried to
emulate some of that flat picking that
he does
those are just a few there's a new guy
named carrie morin out of colorado okay
native american guy just just
just great can sit on a stage with
acoustic guitar that's all he needs
kelly joe phelps you know a deep track
on me here
it's the acoustic guys that can sit
there with just that acoustic and you're
transfixed for a hundred minutes that's
hard to do and i've
uh been fortunate to see some of these
guys live cabin is another one you know
will kimbros another one so yeah jeff
daniels here on the rich eisen show okay
so um
what's the adjective you use to describe
the detroit lion season coming up and
how uh you view it jeff daniels what do
you got for me on that blind face
once again
once again
i know jared goff had some trouble in la
i'd like to think it was a a bad
marriage with the coach
sean mcvay
but the year before he was in the super
bowl that's true
he was he somehow got him to the super
bowl and maybe
different playbook different coaching
staff you got to go in with that it's
it's it's who which jared goff are we
going to get
and and i i you know i know sheila hamp
ford i i i know her well uh sheila full
camp and um
she's all business
this is um she went in there and started
you know throwing people out the window
and uh it was
i loved it and um this is she's it may
take her more than a season you know to
get respectable but i you know
we could go one and we could go
what is it 17 games we could go 2 and 15
or we could go 500 or we could get in
the playoffs i
it's it's
we just don't know and so that's
you know i wish stafford the best in la
right well maybe he's got a team that's
closer to the playoffs out there than
than in detroit but i thought it was a
wonderful
parting of the ways you know stafford i
think went to sheila and company and
just said
you know
mutually beneficial feel free to trade
me you know and feel free to move me and
preferably to a contender which he would
have had to approve so i i think that
was handled really well
and
um i we've got a lot of running backs we
you know i mean you know more about
football sure
i'm wondering what you think of the
coach did you hear dan campbell's
opening press conference when he talked
about biting off kneecaps things like
that what do you think about jeff
daniels what do you think well he's
either
he's either
again blind faith certainly
so when you lead off with biting of
kneecaps
you got to think well he's either a
genius who can motivate players being an
x player and he's speaking their
language or he's a complete idiot i i
don't i i'm i'm
i am hopeful
uh i love the uh it's such a change it's
he he's sticking his chin out onto the
field just like the players so
i'm hoping that he's got some real good
people around him brad holmes i really
like you know the whole scouting history
i think that brad has
uh he knows talent i just like the mix
and if if biting kneecaps speaks to the
players and gets gets them motivated
bite some more you know i had him on the
show a couple months ago and he had a
good sense of humor about it talking
about the you know i brought up the rare
hannibal lecter way of motivating your
team it's very very rare
that you bring in the
silence of the lambs you know to uh to a
situation like that but we'll see how it
all works out i think dan was just
talking about eating kneecaps i think
that's all that i don't think there was
a movie reference in there at all i
think it was just just uh let's go you
know let's go cannibalism on him i don't
know he would but whatever it was i hope
it works and if it works and if we're in
the playoffs
he's a genius he's biting i know jeff
daniels here uh on the rich eisen show
american rust um you get to choose uh uh
what you want to do um i i'm
i'm sure this must have uh intrigued you
um maura tierney and bill camp and an
excellent cast including you
um in this drama which you're playing a
um a town chief of police in the rust
belt in pennsylvania what attracted you
to this role
jeff
uh i drove by heinz field every day on
the way to work so there was that uh the
steelers home um and went to a pirates
game that was great
i love pittsburgh and
um i know these people i grew up in
michigan i i
i am working class i worked at my dad's
lumber company it really is about those
people in the corner of the country who
much like in detroit when the car
companies
left a lot of factories went to mexico
and china same thing happened in
pittsburgh in the 80s with the steel
industry and these people got left
behind
and they're good people
and they're decent people and they just
want to break one break and they're
staring at the bottom and they end up
doing bad things in order to survive and
those people are out there and as as
entertainment goes
i love the storytelling it's
unpredictable you don't know you can
stop every episode and go what happens
next and you'll be wrong
and it just builds and builds and builds
we got really good people on this you
know it's it's not much different than
what the lions are doing or any nfl team
where you bring in the front office
staff and the coaching staff you get
really good people who have a
a history of succeeding at what they do
and you get them on your project like
american rust and then you get out of
their way and you let them go and that's
kind of how this went it's it's i think
it's really strong and if people are
looking for that drama where you don't
know what happens next this is it
and again it starts uh sunday september
12th on showtime at uh 10 p.m eastern
time uh in the minutes i have remaining
with you jeff daniels uh there's a game
we like to play with our celebrity
guests called celebrity true or false
where you
set the record straight on some of the
things that wind up on wikipedia and
some of the other
uh spaces of the internets if you
wouldn't mind playing along i have a few
uh items for you to set the record
straight on if you don't mind jeff
daniels
can't wait okay
i believe you i believe you when you say
that
[Music]
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth
first item up for bids is that um you
were up for the role of joey gladstone
in full house that went to dave coulier
is that true or false
false that is false
yeah there's no there's not even a germ
of truth to something like that not even
a germ and dave coulier
he's back in detroit he's got a house in
detroit now we're we're good friends and
we can pass for not only brothers but
twins okay okay speaking of passing for
brothers uh the movie dumb and dumber
the studio did not want you for it but
jim carrey did
so they low-balled you an offer thinking
you would say no but you took it is that
true or false
true
what did you like about that movie what
you still need you jim jim carrey he had
ace ventura had been out
big hit
and he had shot mask
and it hadn't been released yet when we
started shooting so i i wanted to i
wanted to go into comedy i've been doing
drama and i was it was kind of i was
kind of spinning my wheels and
and so i i said let me do i i went up to
la and chased some jobs and dom and
domer is one of them auditioned i went
back for a call back read with jim and
jim and the fairly brothers wanted me in
the studio wanted you know
a comedian basically and so they gave me
the first week to shoot and where we
shot a lot of my stuff the snowball in
the head the tongue on the pole the skis
inside this key lodge
you know you know harry done scenes and
uh they cut them together on the end of
the first week and they liked what they
saw and i got to stay
and is it true that your your
representation thought you were nuts for
wanting to do that as well that's
another yeah they they thought it was a
huge mistake
and we're not we're going to start it
was an intervention the night before i
was supposed to fly out to l.a to do
dumb and dumber uh we're going to stop
this
uh this is not who you are uh you're a
serious actor and this will ruin your
career and i i i hate to tell you jeff
but
um he's gonna act you off the screen
so i you know i said well juan thanks
for the support two
um he's not in that he's not in the
snowball in the head scene he's not on
the tongue and the pull scene and he's
not in the toilet scene
so those are all mine so unless they cut
those out of the movie
i'm gonna score
and then the next trick well i already
was to let jim lead
you know jim is going to be jim and you
want jim to be jim you want all of that
so don't compete with that be the puppy
on the leash
let him jerk the leash and that put me
on a half second delay
which allowed me to play an iq of eight
because jim as lloyd he would go harry
and i'd go
what you know it's just like you're on a
half second because you're just you know
your brain doesn't work that fast when
he calls your name so
that then we were in we were gold and uh
and jim's a friend to this day i love
the guy
so to this day to this very day jim
carrey's a friend of yours i love that
yeah i was uh you know last couple weeks
i've been in communication yeah that's
great all right i've got a couple more
for you here um you did not think speed
would be successful during filming but
once you saw the final cut you were you
were in on on speed thinking that this
was going to work out that film uh uh uh
you know yeah yes
probably true yes true
what was that what was that i mean shoot
you we we all know about terms of
endearment with with nicholson what was
dennis hopper like were you around him
there weren't many scenes he was great
he was very nice uh picking up a check
uh
as i was and
and i mean it's keanu and it's sandra
bullock and a bus and you're back at
headquarters going what's going on you
know that you know it's not this is not
a career move
this is i need a job move and the first
the the script these and i it was i need
a job and they said well there's this
movie called speed and they sent me the
script and i died on page 22 in the
elevator shaft i didn't even get out of
the elevator shaft and i said look the
career is in trouble but it's not in
that much trouble pass and they go whoa
whoa hang on there's a new draft coming
and you die later
so
that's yeah okay page 88 and then you
know i go into the house and the house
blows up well right outside our studio
is the 105 freeway and i think about
speed every single time i leave the
richardson show studio because they shut
down the freeway
wasn't that freeway that wasn't i don't
even think that freeway was open yet
that was the first ever usage of the 105
free that's probably true it was
probably just before it opened and you
know it was empty and we
keanu got to drive the bus on it yeah
last one for you you were playing keith
olbermann uh as the role of
will mcavoy um in the great show um
newsroom yes true or false no hear your
name
keith thinks that
he keith actually told me we were at
stephen colbert's final show
on comedy central and there's keith
olbermann he comes up to me goes you're
playing me aren't you i said keith god
bless you but no no i mean maybe sorkin
used you i don't know but we never
talked about it he never said by the way
you're doing keith no it was never
brought up if anything i did a couple of
brian williams moves which ryan has a
thing where he puts the elbow down and
his other arm goes straight out he kind
of lean that was my one thing
everything else was made up it was news
to me that keith was
so attached to it i got to be honest
with you i've i work with keith for for
many a moon back in my sports center
days
it did seem on occasion like there were
some ko moments
on that front but now that you mentioned
the anchor lean of
brian williams i mean that is like a
geographic perfect sort of right
triangle that he creates with his body
and the rest of his
yes
someone should paint it yeah
jeff daniels i really appreciate the
time going down memory lane talking
about uh american rust again this sunday
uh sunday september 12 10 p.m eastern
time on show time good luck to the
honolulu blue the old english d with the
tigers looks to be
uh on on a nice upward trend actually
and best of luck on all of that
thanks rich always a pleasure right back
at you that's jeff daniels right here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here